it's me Nick I am light rain would do it
David do so and we're gonna get some
[ __ ] [ __ ] some [ __ ] tacos today
instant regret having you on your dude
if I talk louder tell how they like on
me would you slow down here Mike alright
guys my name is Nick we're here we're
here at the Dollar Tree we're gonna get
some tacos that like unique God talk
about open-mouth kiss you bro well
that's fine and we're just like this
video
[Music]
and one two three go hey guys it's me
Nick could you stutter any more than I
and now yeah so we're here at la única
worried about to get some tacos they're
really good and we're gonna have a good
time today
David regretted taking me here today
because I can feel your vocal chords on
my shoulder blade dude anyways we are
over here cuz you guys already know we
are looking for the best taco spot in LA
and like I said before if you're going
out to like the West LA areas or
something like that you need to come out
to like East LA Boyle Heights aka the
hood and to that lady out there let's
say you don't want East LA is not good
don't say that you're a dumb-dumb and
I'll tell you that I [ __ ] love it
dude because the hood spots are the best
bus I grew up in a hood called South
Sacramento it was fantastic so suck my
nuts so we are here at tacos eb dia la
única and this spot apparently is what
we call the truth and on top of that
we're talking about family recipes
family toys are the best because in my
personal opinion has a lot of heart a
lot of delicious food and of course you
already know and I have a dollar tree
right in the back
this is sponsored by Dollar Tree
[Music]
you know what just as a disclaimer it's
gonna be loud as [ __ ]
I brought these mics apparently the SD
card doesn't work it doesn't [ __ ]
work at all
so we're gonna speak really loud and
hopefully that mic is picking up it's
not then we have to shoot it all over
again you need all this food again
Oh sir the reason why I brought Nick is
because he actually has a Chicano latina
girlfriend and that's the closest thing
I'm again some extra person to come in
with me you know
you know just great food good times you
know the crazy thing is you actually
don't realize who you like until you
really hang out with them one on one
impacts me Rick but Mike isn't even on
dude
well what am I talking to that he's got
stupid my Spanish is really [ __ ] good
all right well let's go from here on out
we're gonna have you guys only do this
in Spanish here we go and go
now all right now you guys already know
I'm out here looking for the best tacos
out in LA Mountain this joint hit me up
through Instagram and I have been
actually stocking this place for the
past couple of months and it's crazy
that they came to me this time cuz that
never happens especially with ladies
this place is actually known for their
media taco so if you don't know how
Biddy has maintained it I know I know
how the day to go and they put it in a
grinder on tape it's gonna kind of have
like that facility where so you have
like ancho chilies you guajillo Chili's
they're like toast is you'll see it with
like cardamom black peppercorns and it's
done in like this constantly broth and
it's slow-cooked in there and it's nice
and tender it's playing
fall-off-the-bone type of [ __ ] and so
their specialty from what they told me
is they're liked Dorado style so they're
fried crunchy taco like video taco with
queso inside and that's what we're going
to try so means cheese probably
non-spanish speakers cheese i'ma eat
this without the sauce the first boy
traveling Cheers um
but I ferry what do you think you know
the one-way trips are [ __ ] flavor
flavortown
so what we have here is a [ __ ]
crunchy delicious estoppel I presence
all I have me Fortius to and I think we
cook it in some of that oil that they
have from like the top of the consummate
because dripping on my head
you see that [ __ ] was driven that's
flavortown juice super [ __ ] is tender
goat that melted queso
I don't know if I even want like to put
the salt on it no I think it was really
good by itself I never really thought
that they it's like it's like the coke
was like a predominant meat that people
would use but this is like the Jalisco
specialty if you don't like goat or you
don't like that type of meat it's not
gamey at all can I taste it not
constantly that it was cooking to all
that game in a suede it's [ __ ] flavor
packed us now look at the continent
so that you
we toss them a dish to
all the time of conventions all right
next up we have the Dorado style style
tacos but instead we have asada and
queso and guacamole guacamole on notice
welcome it's a type of fruit fruit
native to we're gonna choose this [ __ ]
well without any sauce at first
ma
yeah what are they doing to me right now
man it's crazy because even though this
place specializes in media it's a status
to solid which is a great thing about
the crust that's not too crispy it's
like right in the middle I don't know
it's a tortilla you know yep but it's
like look tip this is the constant
see he's gonna do the tip that's more of
a savage he's a he's a I'm gonna to do
this on the port in tonight's date trip
full of classier I put this dude on
camera life is so comfortable now [ __ ]
this good that's the mood right there No
get the consonant and dip the [ __ ]
Dorado tacos in the case of a piece of
Dorado top is so [ __ ] the pouring it
is better cuz it's classier don't do
what he's doing before how I did
oh my god it was just so [ __ ] good
dude
no chakali Mexicali that place is
bombers mugs do they just offer
something different this right here
though I mean if you're looking for
something a little more dank and heavy
oh my god yeah this is just gonna put
you a commission for a little belt
oh well sucks does my guy
yo my barber studs ride go man thanks
David you showed us we're doing a
mukbang right now we're food oh yeah hey
there you go make a lot of noise while
you're doing that's all the muck made
people they they open their eyes the
bumper beam are so [ __ ] ridiculous
they'll do some [ __ ] like this they're
like hey guys so today we're eating a
napkin
next up my friends we have their mom's
pedo
now I told you guys last night we went
to chick alley what about Rita was what
is that toasted tortilla on that bottom
cousin with case so on the bottom cousin
and over here David with dress tada
and they're wakka moly I've never had a
vampiro before dude it's the [ __ ] you've
never had a map here you're so
uncultured do whatever you I have I had
it the first time like a couple nights
ago though you are the master of your
vamp you know so you could do it however
you'll own like that Cheers
is it gonna fall part of me
why
what don't give you out in it that's so
good
no can we talk about ropes later there's
a ballpark come [ __ ] delicious
they're [ __ ] awesome Elias we're
gonna keep eating he's been described
him fight the color of the Rojas awesome
it's not as spicy as as much but it's
roasted as a [ __ ] deep flavor to it
and that's what I like it no the only
thing I had to say about it
I knew what roasted taste like I was
gonna say that you stole that from I
hate these whiskers on your face I know
I was gonna be on camera today what do
you think about your first time here oh
it's great I have no other frame
reference but I'm sure this is [ __ ]
top-notch it's really good
not a bounce it's not about out of mouth
now
right was not [ __ ] love guy fearing
like I don't like any of it he had a
restaurant I'm suckin on context wasabi
like [ __ ] was trash
it was so [ __ ] bad however I still
support Guy Fieri I love that guy to
death I don't know why but he always
makes me look good
this right here is like meat not like a
so like tirado version which is with
their handmade tortillas once in it is
not handmade I don't [ __ ] 100 turns
our image right and you can already tell
right here just right here was a goat
and that [ __ ] dead as hell all
that delicious like Liberia meat my goat
needs soak right into that courtier and
his swearing to dress it up
I'll put that tomatillo salsa in there
today we're not adding all like the
cilantro the next one it takes that meat
in the delicious Cordia tab it
let's [ __ ] salt flavor soaks in oh my
god it's right here - let's [ __ ] song
oh my god just crazy because I've always
had my favorite spot and those spots
like I said Avenue 26 salad always 24/7
solid [ __ ] chocolate one
but it doesn't mean that you know look
at this pull the [ __ ] right off the
[ __ ] bone like nothing dude
all that like connective tissue that
that is right there she's so good
I'm so [ __ ] happy if you guys are out
in Boyle Heights man you guys already
know this place got that Davis oh scam
but well this is tacos obedia la única
check it out it's going to be a truck as
bright red as [ __ ] this place is the
[ __ ] if you come here you don't like it
you're disappointed you don't like go I
will literally chop off your feet yeah
you will
you never invited to another video start
some Oh
put then put it but it's on okay
that girl was right about water and I
don't want to like talk in front of
cameras but when why I see David at work
it's just weird you know low kick
alright guys that's how it's [ __ ]
done alright there's a film industry guy
right here [ __ ] talking to bids
showbiz baby
we're [ __ ] rolling in it am i right
take the start from the top let's go
you got talking to the Michael do you
got any my yeah yeah do the intro again
this is how your car should go yeah you
gotta show the belt buckle yeah baby
alright guys we're here at [ __ ]
Dollar Tree we're gonna get some tacos
around the corner talk with Iberia yeah
called a collar draft I think oh I take
it back just like that baby take my ass
just like that yep we were supposed to
cut like five minutes nobody's talking
whatever dude you're [ __ ] this guy
doesn't even know
[Music]
let me know am I talking too quiet this
is David so this comedy channel so